[Music]
lane is on the line to start off this
hour lane is in kansas city hi elaine
how are you
hey dave ken thanks for taking my call
sure what's up
yeah so i just had a quick question so i
currently have
uh 14 300 left on the car
i could get that paid off in february
but i don't know if i should
pay that off first or just save up
for
our first child that's going to come in
april
uh when you're having a baby on the way
we tell folks to push pause
on their baby steps push pause on their
debt snowball and pile up cash
okay so you
i would not pay off your car i would
just pile up cash as big a pile as you
can have okay and just how do you stack
cash like you were trying to pay off the
debt but just put it in your own account
never touch it for anything unless
there's an emergency
and then when mom and baby come home
from the hospital and everybody's
healthy and everybody's safe you push
play again which means that day you're
gonna pay off your
okay okay you won't have lost anything
except a little bit of interest on your
car between now and the time baby comes
and right now we're focusing on more
important things than car debt and
that's baby
okay understand that i bet you do how
exciting
yeah it's very exciting your first one
yes all right
fun good for you man how old are you
guys
uh i'm 24 and she's 26. cool
yeah so you're gonna have several
thousand dollars towards your baby step
three
above your fourteen thousand dollars
for the car debt uh because the car will
evolve just by paying the payments you
will have reduced the principal some and
you're going to save more and you said
february was your target date and
april's a baby so you would have already
saved you know several thousand beyond
you should have 16 17 000 bucks saved
and when you pay off the car you got a
good start towards your baby step three
then following me
yeah we currently have 7 400 saved up in
savings right now oh so you're not
really working the baby steps
i mean we we are no no you weren't
either baby step one's a thousand
dollars everything above that goes
towards the car but now the baby's
coming it's okay we're gonna push pause
anyway and we're gonna pile up the cash
okay
all right
thanks for the call bro
open phones at eight eight two five five
two two five
so ken uh you might get called out on
this show
even if you're a nice young guy with
your first baby on the way i might still
smack you around a little bit yeah if
you act like you're working the baby
steps and you're not that's right
there's a reason why you've got seven of
them and they actually go in order and
they make a lot of sense same thing with
the paycheck to purpose that's right you
know you got to get clear and you know
i'm kind of working this but i'm not
clear no you're not working it yet
that's so true you know there's a
process here that's proven and they're
gonna go with that process yeah you
gotta you gotta walk a plan you know no
matter where you are in your life maybe
it's physical fitness maybe it's uh some
health stuff relationship stuff going on
when you have a gap between where you
are and where you wanna be
there is always going to be steps
to build that bridge if you will and you
walk across that bridge to where you
want to be and you got to follow it you
absolutely have to follow it yeah and
we're we're hardcore about it and the
reason is it works well ish is a wish
every time you issue it right you slow
down your progress well can you lower
the probability of actually hitting it
that's right so let's take his scenario
let's say baby wasn't on the way he's
new to us whatever he is you know and
he's going okay i'm gonna pay it off in
february and he's juiced that savings
baby step one is a thousand dollars he's
juiced it to 7 400 and and and what he
could have done instead of kind of
holding that back worrying about
something
to play it out the way that you've
taught it for decades
then he's so much further along in
paying off that car and paid off by
halloween that's right then
that goes towards how quickly he gets
his emergency fund set and then that
goes into 15
and so everything fast forwards when you
actually walk our plan out yeah yeah so
you know
just just be ready that um if you say i
don't understand them that's okay we're
not gonna pick on you for that
but um yeah so so
do this stuff the way guys we've had 10
million people go through financial
peace university
this is not our first ride on this
cabbage truck
so we want to help you
we we want you to do but but you know we
the shortest
right way from where you are to wealth
is what we've laid out and we're going
to do that with you every single time